foreign
what's happening
you changed the future
you changed the path
what did you do
want some help you're you are you're
yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
foreign
watch the full trailer online now
the flash only appears June 16th
tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay and fight to
save this one
because this is the world where my mom
lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
magnets
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything just kept
me happening
really broke the universe
besides we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
here
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
hey Miss Kara Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
going to see this
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
[Music]
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
[Music]
he just hated things the way they are
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to if I beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
[Music]
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
and beautiful beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
notice how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
Dominic Toretto how do you choose the
ones you save Let's Race
he's coming for you with everything
you're about to learn all about fear
s
[Music]
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
I never accept death when suffering is
over
you made one mistake you never took my
car
see you soon Dom
I'm ready
here I come cause I'm ready
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
but he doesn't anymore
hey I'm just getting started little
brother
I'm coming for everything
[Applause]
I'll let him destroy everything you've
built
here I come
we're facing the greatest evil
the world has ever known
we're gonna need a team
[Music]
foreign
Dungeons and Dragons
[Music]
you know when you get a Feeling
I'm doing this 20 years I've never had a
feeling like this you're gonna see
exactly what I see this is what
greatness I need the greatest basketball
shoe that's ever been made what's the
plan we build a shoe line around just
him for a rookie who's never set foot on
an NBA court who's the player Michael
Jordan
we can't get Michael Jordan I'm thinking
of reaching out to the parents you talk
directly to the family you're gonna lose
your job do you typically show up at
people's front doors unannounced I was
told not to call oh man here we go
every once in a while someone comes
along that's so extraordinary that it
forces change because they are so very
special a shoe is just a shoe until my
son steps into it
air way to DAR exclusive in theaters
April 5th
[Applause]
oh yeah
relax a mirage remember
[Music]
thank you
65 exclusively in movie theaters March
10th you have we met my memory is a
little fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
[Music]
[Applause]
doing here
[Music]
we're too high off we can get down from
here
you're almost here
thank you
[Applause]
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place
it's a shrine
guys
we
execute him
come on mother scream
it's for you
finally in theaters March 10th tickets
on sale now